so much for keeping secrets ever since
they witnessed half of their favorite
superheroes disintegrate in Avengers
infinity war Marvel fans have been on
the edge of their seats wondering how
things will turn out in the fourth
Avengers movie
after what felt like an eternity Marvel
Studios released the movie's first
trailer in December 2018 revealing the
title of the film to be Avengers endgame
but when the studio dropped the footage
it also broke a few hearts the first
look at the film was hardly a triumphant
one the teaser showed Robert Downey jr.
--zz Tony Stark floating aimlessly
through space low on food and oxygen and
seemingly preparing to die instead of
rallying for a vengeful strike against
Thanos his nemesis the only glimpse we
saw of Iron Man was him recording a
farewell message to fiance Pepper Potts
while some began preparing to say
goodbye to the billionaire fat boy
others started speculating that another
hero would swoop in to save Tony from
the brink of certain death one Theory
assembled evidence that pepper herself
would do the saving by finally assuming
her comic-book alter ego of rescue to
somehow bring her bow back home just the
record being interested space with zero
promises rescue has more fun that sounds
but a recent announcement from the car
company od may have inadvertently
spoiled who will actually save Tony's
life an endgame during a presentation at
January 2019 s Consumer Electronics Show
howdy announced that it it partnered
with Marvel to develop a VR experience
that ties in with endgame the
cross-promotion will allow fans to
venture through space from the backseat
of outies e tron vision Gran Turismo the
vehicle will be making an appearance in
endgame supposedly with an alive and
well Tony Stark behind the wheel well I
mean I ABS Tony Stark and Avengers for
it this development seemed to confirm
that Tony will make his way back to
earth in the fourth avengers adventure
and in good enough condition to feel
like zipping around in a sweet luxury
two-seater the idea that Tony will
survive his job through space if true
barely feels like a spoiler it never
seemed likely that he'd actually die out
there but an important question remained
who would be the one to rescue him
aspects of Audis promotion strongly
suggest that the hero who saves Tony
might be none other than Rocket Raccoon
which would surely come as a
Nitori experience for the oxygen-starved
dehydrated earthling
the details are all in the title of a DS
vr experience marvel's avengers rockets
rescue run the game will apparently have
players slide into the e-tron gt's
backseat where they'll control another
vehicle as though they were rocket on a
spacefaring rescue mission though the
name of the game alone doesn't specify
who rocket is rescuing it certainly
implies that rocket might be the one who
comes to Tony's aid Tony is in Rockets
spaceship after all and at the start of
Avengers endgame it would appear that
he'll need rescuing more than anyone
else well as long as we're not counting
the people who got dusted did Audi
really release promotional details that
spoil this aspect of endgame thanks to
an in-depth account of rescue run from
the verge writer Sean o Cain it appears
pretty likely that's exactly what
happened and a piece published on
January 7th
just ahead of Audis presentation CES
O'Kane wrote Ironman needs help he's
being chased through outer space by
summit Thanos his baddies so Rocket
Raccoon and I rushed to his aid we make
a few jumps using the universal neural
teleportation Network and a few
rollicking minutes later I helped blast
the enemies to bits small leaks about
potential plot details happen all the
time with movies this high profile but
it's pretty wild to think that the
famously unfort coming Marvel might have
let this spoiler slip it's possible that
the studio could have revealed this info
as a fake out as they've done before
putting out misleading information to
muddy the waters when it comes to actual
leaks on the flipside it's also possible
that this reveal is genuinely a
marketing miscalculation that reveals
too much too soon
both possibilities seem equally likely
and are sure to fuel online debate as
the movie's much anticipated release
draws closer as things stand now there's
a solid chance that endgame will see
that galaxy's most beloved trash panda
head to space save Tony and haul him
back to earth to reunite with the other
surviving heroes then they can formulate
a plan to take down Thanos revived the
Fallen Heroes and then take a joyride in
this cool new whip to celebrate the job
well done
cannot believe it man I have not driven
one of these in a while so does this
theory hold water from a story
standpoint rocket saving Tony would make
a lot of sense the end game trailer
revealed that Tony and nebula will
escape Titan on board the benatar the
ship star-lord commandeer the last time
we saw rocket he was stranded on earth
and Wakanda watching helplessly as
several heroes including his best buddy
Groot fell away to nothingness he's the
only Guardian to have made it out of
thin OSes decimation with his life
intact but at the end of infinity war he
has no way of knowing that so it's
reasonable that rocket will start off in
game fiercely determined to locate as
missing teammates and where else would
he start looking for them than their own
spaceship as plausible as all this
sounds right now it's only a theory and
no one outside of Marvel knows for sure
how Tony will make it back home we'll
keep our eye on the developments but the
only way to be sure what really happens
will be to wait patiently for the
movie's premiere on April 26th you
what's your secret
mellow jazz bongo drums huge bag of weed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]